[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and the series called High School
memories my name is Lisa and I'll be
your host today so without further Ado
let's dive into today's episode and
embark on a great journey together get
ready to be engaged entertained and
inspired today's topic will be about the
social dilemma a gripping documentary
that peels back the layers on the darker
side of social media trust me it's a
real eye opener for anyone who's ever
considered these platforms a mere
nuisance so make sure to grab your
popcorn and buckle up because we've got
a lot to
cover first and foremost let's talk
about the alarming connection between
social media and our mental health the
statistics are staggering with Rising
rates of depression anxiety eating
disorders and in the most
heart-wrenching cases even
suicide it's no longer a secret that
these platforms play a significant role
in shaping our emotional well-being it
is truly a wakeup call for all of us the
social dilemma exposes some unsettling
truths about the Giants of tech Facebook
Google Instagram Twitter and more our
protagonist here is Tristan haris a
former design ethicist for Google he's
been in the belly of the Beast and knows
the drill Harris recognized The
Addictive nature of these platforms and
their impact on our thoughts he found it
fascinating how no one at gmail worked
on making it less
addictive and he said that two billion
people will have thoughts that they
didn't intend to have only because a
designer at Google said this is how
notifications work on that screen that
you wake up to in the
morning that's why he sent a
presentation to his colleagues but
despite unanimous agreement nothing
changed he explains how a lot of people
think that Google is just another search
box but they don't realize that they're
constantly competing for our
attention that's right tech companies
are battling for our attention ever
wondered how Facebook keeps you
scrolling for hours and hours on end in
the film we learned that the company of
Facebook has conducted countless
experiments on users fine-tuning their
manipulation techniques over time by
running these experiments they developed
a way to get users to do what they want
us to do
manipulation their business model is
keeping our eyeballs glued to the screen
for more add Revenue they can affect
real world behavior and emotions without
triggering the users's
awareness but Facebook isn't alone in
this game Snapchat Twitter Youtube and
others have the same Playbook we are not
the customers advertisers are change of
behavior and perception is the real
product it can change what we do how we
think who we are and so much more now
let's talk about Pinterest the app
that's all about
inspiration Tim Kendall former president
of Pinterest shared his experiences in
the documentary he knew the tricks of
the trait and explained how he was
working on building something during the
day that he was falling into himself so
he knew what was going on behind the
scenes but even he struggled to curb his
usage we all make promises about not
using our phones in hour before sleep
only to break them in the end it's
easier said than done isn't it Snapchat
WS the king of ephemeral content now
ranks among the worst for mental health
Snapchat dysmorphia is a term coined in
the documentary referring to patients
seeking surgery to look like their
filtered selves the app fuels body
Consciousness Eating Disorders bullying
and fomo which is fear missing out both
in Dap and in real life so not only is
our activity within the app toxic but so
is what it does to our activity outside
of the app studies show that spending
more than two hours a day on social
media is a ticket to poor mental health
including anxiety and depression you
think YouTube is innocent think again a
worker there raised the alarm about
their algorithm which is designed to
keep us online online he was worried
that an algorithm he worked on was
increasing polarization in
society this polarization was extremely
efficient at keeping people online
people think that the algorithm is
designed to give people what they want
but it's not the algorithm is actually
trying to find a few rabbit holes that
are very powerful and are trying to find
which rabbit hole is closest to our
interest that's exactly why if you start
watching a video YouTube will recommend
similar ones over and over again it's
all about pushing the content that
matches our interests even if they're
conspiracy theories or
falsehoods this algorithm is an expert
at creating Echo Chambers fueling
polarization and changing what we
believe gen Z those born after 1996
including me are the first generation to
be raised in the era of social media
they spend more time glued to screens
than ever before and it's taking a all
they're more anxious depressed and
insecure with issues like body image and
loneliness On The Rise the brain's
ability to process information changes
because of overexposure to
technology the constant exposure to
technology is rewiring their brains and
leading to tragic
consequences and here's the kicker fake
news on platforms like Twitter spreads
six times faster than the truth Tristan
Harris mentions that they make money the
more they allow unregulated messages to
reach anyone for the best price
algorithms and manipulative politicians
are becoming so expert at learning how
to trigger us and getting so good at
creating fake news that we absorb it as
if it were reality it say though we have
less and less control over who we are
and what we believe and that's a scary
thought so the social dilemma leaves us
with a powerful message these social
media companies thrive on capturing our
attention and it's time for us to
reconsider our digital habits as one
memorable quote from the documentary
says were we evolved to be aware of what
10,000 people think of us we were not
evolved to have social approval being
dosed to us every 5 minutes it's a stark
reminder that our lives don't revolve
around the digital approval of others
your opinion matters and it doesn't have
to Echo the
masses so there you have it folks a
comprehensive look at the social dilemma
it's high time we reflect on our digital
lives their impact on our mental health
and the future of our society stay tuned
for more thought-provoking discussions
on our next episodes until then remember
that your voice matters in this Digital
World don't be just another echo in the
chamber thanks for tuning in and joining
us on this episode of high school
memories it's been an incredible journey
and we're so glad you came along for the
right until next time take
care
[Music]